[Music]
it's a tale as onlys time a song as old
as rhyme and enchantress turning an
11-year old into a feral monster who ten
years later traps a girl in a castle
until she loves it
you know that old chestnut Beauty and
the Beast welcome to this poor
provincial French village where everyone
has an American accent it's not right
for a woman to read and meet Belle
daughter of the local killing machine
Adventure Belle longs for adventure and
she'll get just that when she's
kidnapped by the Beast a prince who's so
bad at his job he's been missing for ten
years and no one seems to notice
watch romance bloom between her and
Prince him they never do say his name do
they in this fairy tale that teaches
every kid it's what's on the inside that
counts but it doesn't have to be so rich
you own a castle with its own librarians
of magic slaves cheer as this strong
smart independent woman rejects this
violent controlling bad mannered hairy
dude who imprisoned her dad for this
dude who imprisoned czar dad wait why
does he lock up her dad
the dude clearly wants to be left alone
I'll give you a place to stay could me
just you know let him leave and get
eaten by wolves or something that seems
a lot easier than feeding an old man for
decades but Belle isn't alone she's
trapped with dozens of living objects
that raise dozens of uncomfortable
questions like did everything that moves
used to be a person like are all those
plates people and what happened to all
the actual stuff did it merge with the
servants will they go to trial for
murdering all those villagers that
Bureau straight-up crushes that guy
if the beasts turned the curse why did
all his servants get deformed too then
this movie is messed up so be Disney's
guest at this tale as old as Stockholm
Syndrome
which was the first animated feature to
be nominated for Best Picture
blood loss to a movie with a very
similar plot you will join me for dinner
he rubs the lotion on its skin or else
it gets the hose again
and managed to distract us from it's
messed up story with some of Disney's
most beloved songs like the I'm too good
for this place are you the bookshop I
just finished the most wonderful story
but you probably don't know how to read
Christ you read no one cares
[Music]
the sucking yourself up saw the it sucks
to work you saw do I head stuff your
face we are both stuck in this place we
got here with no idea we turned into an
Ikea there's no growth there's no day
and
without sit here all day just because my
boss was a deep I become a French
candlestick none of us deserved it
our poor friends
[Music]
I must confess we are oppressed get
snapped in half if we pretend we saw
sleep
and the toxic relationships are
[Music]
and to family
caged lion killer aged unpredictably
[Music]
we can't get away you can't be
a constant fear is trapped in there
please cold story the CrossFit bro
a pity Lefou berry guy in a little coat
must love dogs
this French guy's on fire it's always
4:30 5:00 somewhere tea she poured and
this young boy in an old man's mouth
Saved by the Bell
do I still have to sleep in the cupboard
you have 20 brothers and sisters so yeah
you probably do hey screen junkies want
even more Disney magic then be our guest
and click the box in the left to watch
our honest trailer for Moana or click
the box in the right to look in our
chanted mirror as we rank every Disney
Princess and find out who is the best of
the best
don't be a guest on check it out now no
one appears in an honest trailer by
Gaston ohana means family and family
means no one gets left behind Logan I
have to pee I used to be a trailer but I
became honest the Twilight books are
literally the best thing ever made